films nominated for the Academy Award
this year are all the President's Men a
Wildwood Enterprises production Warner
Brothers Walter Colburn's producer Bound
for Glory the Bound for Glory company
production United Artists Robert F blue
moth and Harold Leventhal producers
Network a Howard gottfried paddy
Chayefsky production metro-goldwyn-mayer
United Artists Howard Gottfried producer
rocky a Robert chart Hoff Irwin Winkler
production United Artists Kerwin Winkler
and Robert chard off producers
taxi-driver a bill - Philips production
of a Martin Scorsese film Columbia
Pictures Michael Phillips and Julia
Phillips producers
and the winner is rocky
Irwin Winkler and Robert chart off the
goose
Sylvester Stallone I'd like to thank you
for sharing your dream of rocky with us
and for giving a performance that has
enriched all our lives
I'd like to thank John avildsen for his
sensitive Direction Jean Kirkwood for
his imagination and energy and finally
the Academy was permitted rocky a
million-to-one underdog go the distance
tonight thank you very much
there were many people behind the scenes
that helped us really achieve my dream
Arthur Krim erequest cow Mike Medavoy
and Gabe Sumner United all were very
very responsible for us being here today
they really helped all of us live out
the dream of rocky and to all the
Rockies in the world I love it
you